well here's here's the new narrative
this is what we get we got this from the
guardian us could be under right-wing
Dictator by 2030. Canadian Professor
warns Canadian political scientist warns
an op-ed of trumpist threat to American
democracy and possible effect on
Northern neighbor I love other like
right-wing dictatorship is coming and
they show a picture of trump I gotta be
honest and I'm not trying to be mean not
not I'm not entirely convinced Donald
Trump will even be alive in 2030. eight
years from now will be in his late 80s
mid to late 80s okay I mean that's well
above average life expectancy for uh on
the average American adult male but
maybe I gotta be honest Trump is pretty
spry so he could be but under a
right-wing dictator see I'll tell you
what they're doing they're just trying
to generate fear to scare the left to
get them to Rally around something but I
I tell you a mannequin will not be Trump
Donald Trump is that big imposing figure
the left coward and feared and now
they're like but look at this in
invisible Specter of right-wing trumpism
and it's like yo I don't know what that
is I don't see anything there it's
Hollow your argument is trash I mean
they'll have to they'll have to betray
whoever comes next as worse than Trump
right because it's like it's like you
have a television series and they're
like oh the next season's nowhere near
as exciting you know it's gonna be
boring actually like No One's Gonna
watch it right they're using the same
principles as like as like entertainment
or infotainment
um which you know I I think
it's not even a a choice between whether
they really believe this or they don't I
think a really good like propaganda
believes what they're saying right like
I think a lot of people on the left have
have convinced themselves that democracy
is like five seconds away from you know
disappearing that allows them to
protract that same image to the rest of
of the planet I think okay you correct
they're going to have to say that
whoever comes next is worse than Trump
the problem is take a look at this
article from the Independent Trump's
denial of climate change represents
worse threat to humanity than Hitler
says activist Noam Chomsky look at this
dude man whoa yikes bro
Noam Chomsky is that famous uh video
where it's like in the 70s and he's
defending Free Speech even for those who
disagree with now he's become this like
disheveled old crackpot communist and
but here's my main point if they're now
saying in more ways than one that Trump
is worse than Hitler here's an article
from Newsweek a woman tweeted Hitler was
better than Trump and Twitter won't say
whether she broke its rules if they
actually believe that then
then what do they say about the next guy
like he's the Antichrist or something
did you guys watch this Netflix movie
don't look up yes yeah okay I liked it
well okay yeah I thought it was a fun
movie in terms of it being watchable and
actually someone I had worked with in
the past David Sirota helped co-write it
so I you know I'm not trying to be mean
about it but like one of the things the
movie really gets wrong is that okay so
the plot of the movie for those haven't
seen it is that a comet is heading
towards the Earth it's gonna be there in
six months and the news media and
politicians spoiler alerts just in case
oh yeah it's a still a new movie all
right I'll do mild displays won't give
anything too much weight but basically
the the the the Arc of the plot is that
the media and politicians don't take it
seriously like they don't really care
that a comet's gonna head towards the
Earth and Destroy everybody and you know
I watched that and I just thought to
myself it it doesn't have any bearing on
reality because like if there was a
comet heading towards the earth I think
CNN would have like a comet hologram you
know I think they would have 25 watch
they would have like 25 intersectional
takes on the comment every day like what
the comment is gonna do to women
authorities like you know like like the
media the media in this country is
driven by fear it's not always fear of
stuff you really should be all that
scared of I would say but like they
understand that for yourselves a fear
gets clicks and there's absolutely no
way that they will uh pass up the
challenge of an actual world ending
Disaster by the way climate change is
bad in many ways but it's not actually a
world-ending disaster like the planet
will still exist the ecosystem will
still like this humans will still exist
it'll change a comet with and that's a
really good point I can imagine Don
Lemon doing you know Comet watch and
they have like they're the sidebar and
it's like miles you know time till hits
the Earth and like miles traveled and
then there will be like a special
presentation where they like look at the
sky and they have like a reporter on the
ground we're here in New York at the top
of the Empire State Building you can
look up you can start to see it forming
they wouldn't never stop bit of panels
discussing like no no they would have
reenactments they would have animated
reenactment reenactments of people dying
or getting obliterated they would have a
death counter how many people are going
to die and how many people are going to
suffer every every segment would be
yelling at the president prep Mr
President how dare you not blow up that
comment you know you have to do this
immediately like it would be five alarm
car fire we know that because that's
what happened with Cove at night right
right which was far less severe than a
comet strike in the year so I just you
know it's a fun movie I think it was an
enjoyable watch but I do think that the
writers kind of just missed it like
that's that's not the way the media
operates there's a meme I saw where it's
the the wojack face all happy and it's
got the full political Compass over the
face looking at the movie saying wow
it's it's proving me right and making
fun of my political Rivals like the
movie made fun of literally everyone
that's why I thought it was all right
but it was obvious what the narrative
was the message was that climate change
is serious the scientists are warning us
and no one takes it seriously but I
think you're right I think the fear is
is too juicy for them to give up but
there's also a lot of people
desensitized as you were just talking
about a few moments ago people are angry
people are fed up I absolutely believe
that's the case especially with covet
especially with just how horribly the
government messed up and how you would
argue that every step of the way they
made the situation that much worse
there's a lot of evidence to suggest
that but at a certain point I think
enough people say hey I'm just sick of
this this is not going to affect me
there's only so many times you could
lunge out and scream Boo at somebody
before they're like okay this doesn't
really work at all and I think this is
why there's a victory that we're having
here that we need to note and that is
that news corporate news media
viewership by and large has been going
down by the years and it has continued
to go down and I think that's a huge
Victory and I think people are just
getting so desensitized so out of touch
with it or they're just going on Zoloft
and other ssris but but but there's also
a small section of that but then
majority of people are saying this is
not scary anymore it's like a Halloween
ride that just you know loses its its
Factor after going on it so many times
it's called yeah it's like it's a form
of bias that like probably all the news
has which is called negativity bias
right like they're always trying to tell
you how the world's like going hell in a
handbasket right and at a certain point
why does someone want to sit there and
watch that every single day even in the
most trivial circumstances you know
finding a woman in Central Park who's
rude to somebody or something and
putting the video on national news like
right at a certain point someone's gonna
be like why am I watching this over and
over like why why am I getting this
distorted view of the world why are they
trying to make me miserable I don't I
don't think that's it because I think
you can you can uh Levy some of that
criticism towards us as well you know we
we sing we see things in the news and we
we highlight like wow we think this is
pretty bad and something needs to be
addressed to be fair though you know if
you even look at some of the stories we
did over like to the start of the show
like Joe Rogan leading the charge to to
go against censorship is fairly neutral
censorship is bad but people fighting
back is good so we we try not to be
always very negative but I think we're
very negative however I think cable TV
is driven specifically by editorial
demand for negativity which is it's
different from here like we have actual
we we're just we're people with opinions
before we start the show we sit down I
say like hey Luke what have you seen in
the news what do you think is important
and Luke's got a bunch of stories like
riots are happening here or this happens
and then we'll try and figure out what
we think is like the most important
thing that we should talk about what
what matters most to people in terms of
what's Happening
for me I thought the Joe Rogan thing was
big because such a big celebrity to push
back against censorship and I don't see
that as a negative for the most part
kind of just is
but CNN we learned this thanks to real
journalists like project Veritas when
you get that CNN producer saying that
covid deaths were gangbusters for
Ratings they put that big old thing
death counter on the on the TV think
about how Despicable that is man and
celebrating and being happy about it
that they were able to get ratings
because of that fear that's another
layer of it that really needs to be
understood by people who consume media
they should understand what they're
getting and who they're getting it from
and when they're getting the news from
CNN you don't want to know who you're
getting it from when you find out holy
cow I mean I think news media always has
to address problems like you know I made
a couple of documentaries with Fox over
the past year in different locations but
I think in terms of addressing the
problems you should also be addressing
Solutions like you should also be
constructive you should be trying to
figure out like how do we solve this
like what are what are people doing
about it and I think the difference
between people sitting around talking
about problems like we are and what CNN
does is like CNN doesn't care if there
ever is a solution to the problem CNN is
just there to tell you that everything's
horrible and you need to be addicted to
us to keep telling you how horrible
they're incentivized to make it more
horrible because when they do they get
more viewership because of that so and
and I think this is in response to a lot
of their coverage which is in my opinion
leading to some real life harm
I gotta tell you man
you're constantly just watching what's
going on you know people have asked me
like man it must must get to you
sometimes and I'm like you know it's
it's not the news it's it's it's it's
more like the personal aspect when I'm
when I'm reading stories about news
policy worldly Affairs that's not a big
deal but when I read about
incessant behaviors that's really
um it it it it's it's black pilling when
you see like Hey we're experiencing the
same problem again because people just
do the same thing over and over again it
kind of feels like a human macro level
problem that's in intrinsic to humans
like why do he why do people in New York
keep voting for ocasio-cortez well they
don't read the news they don't watch the
news they get their their information
from Word of Mouth they don't pay
attention so they're trapped in this
cycle and I don't see that as
ever-changing I really don't until the
maybe the pot boils over and it knocks
off the stove or something for the time
being AOC can say like oh we gotta have
mask mandates you know Texas is killing
people and then go party in Miami
because she knows her constituents won't
read the news and she gets away with it
so that that's the kind of thing where
I'm just like man all of this could stop
and we could make a Minecraft Channel
and just talk about you know the well I
don't even think about Minecraft
creepers creepers yeah yeah the creepers
oh they're getting to us you know it's
all you know but instead it's just like
the same thing every day we've been
talking about censorship for a decade
and it's been getting worse we've been
talking about you you know many of these
cultural issues the Banning of Comedy
for for five six seven years and it just
keeps getting worse and at a certain
point it's like are people going to keep
behaving the exact same way is anything
going to change or do we are we stuck in
a loop but maybe maybe it's not a loop
maybe it's a downward spiral that
eventually just reaches the point where
we're spinning so fast I still I still
think the fact that we're still here is
a victory the fact that Against All Odds
the algorithm changes the tweaks the
demonetizations the just deliberate
efforts to stop any kind of independent
speech the fact that there's still some
resilient people out there building
infrastructure building their own bases
is is a victory in itself and we're very
blessed to still be here and still be
able to still keep up the fight in some
kind of way sorry I cut you off there no
I was just saying that like let's
remember also like we're talking about
this covet emergency State like
the world came together governments came
together business came together
Pharmaceuticals came together we all
like dramatically altered our lifestyles
in ways that we've never done before
people were you know doing these maths
people were social distancing it was
lockdowns all this happened and like you
said we're still here right they
developed vaccines most people have
gotten through this thankfully this
disease is actually not very harmful
from children at all people are slowly
waking up to that
um we survived this much better than we
have past pandemics right it's nothing
like Spanish flu so on and so forth and
I think that that's like a positive
thing right like we can't get too down
on ourselves and say that oh America
reacted to this so poorly you know we're
so stupid you know take that don't look
up view of the United States we can also
look at the fact that we actually the
average American did tons of stuff in
response to this that we'd never done
before we a lot of us did kind of rise
to some kind of calling even to some of
these policies were misguided
um and we're all still here like we
survived this and we're going to survive
this I'm actually fairly optimistic on
on where we're going in the future I I
just feel like after seven or eight
years of the same things happening over
and over again my what I mean to say is
the thing that's annoying and
frustrating doing this job is that you
hear the same stories on repeat you know
sometimes they're slightly different
sometimes they're just regurgitated and
it's you just kind of wish people would
learn and change their behaviors but I
think the issue is that humans are
um human civilization is is emergent
it's constantly in flux with younger
people aging and dying and younger and
then younger people coming in taking
over so you end up with people like uh
vosh for instance who comes on the show
and said he didn't know anything about
the Obama administration because he was
just a teenager but now he's a major you
know force in political commentary on
the internet not the biggest channel in
the world but he's fairly large he gets
a lot of views and he's having a
conversation about politics when he
wasn't around for what Obama had done
and Biden as well
so he's lacking that experience that
makes it impossible for Humanity to to
effectively learn in a sense and not not
completely just in in some areas however
I I do think that people are going to
get to a point where they just slam the
table and say I'm mad as hell I'm not
going to take it anymore and that's why
I think Democrats are resigning or
retiring or planning to retire in huge
numbers thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel Monday through Friday at 8
pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this Channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time